I'm so [ __ ] tired look at this face
look how sad he is we're we're back on
square one YouTube Bravo Bravo
you did it is this how it's gonna be now
I'll just have to make a video every
time there's a problem cuz otherwise no
one gives a [ __ ] all's I've been
enjoying [ __ ] on YouTube let's have
a little look at the comments shall we
hey Oh Cara vlogs kids there is a secret
ending I want to tell more 718 lengths
well it was a great comment made by a
pretty lady right yeah I'm just making a
point
it's common it's obviously fake why did
700 of you like this comment there's
another one identical to it 626 likes
and guess what there's another identical
the original come these [ __ ]
they take comments that got a lot of
likes they copy and paste them and boom
hey hey a cute girl in the picture I
never had an interaction with a lady
before
oh boy here I come that was a funny
comment he right here I go here I go
oh [ __ ] are you guys that pathetic are
you that [ __ ] stupid can y'all stop
thinking with your dicks for one [ __ ]
second look at what's underneath it
Peter pie if you are reading this you
are so lucky go to special surprise for
all of you
let's select you know what you can track
the data of these links let's see how
many of your [ __ ] idiots clicked on
this [ __ ] 6000 and that's counting from
yesterday that's good I mean come on you
want you horny bastards are ruining my
channel all right Cara vlogs first of
all why don't you call yourself with
like a normal [ __ ] name like Laura
blogs or some [ __ ] there's different
variations of these alright I've seen
them cara vlogs sara vlogs petrucha
vlogs okay stop if you sub me I will sub
back with 34 accounts hey let's give it
a go
just [ __ ] kidding your [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright I don't even know where to begin
in this mess first of all oh my god I've
said this for years I've said this for
longer than I begged for the diamond
play button this is for you too
why the why the hell what why why can
people create accounts with your name in
it a couple years ago before the Google+
apocalypse you could have one name per
person it could not be two PewDiePie's
only one who thought it was a good idea
to let that be a thing what the [ __ ] are
you guys thinking like do I have to say
this right like I said it for years no
one listens at YouTube at these sort of
things why can they do this
it is mind-blowingly stupid yes there is
a check mark by my name not everyone
knows about that just don't let them
create a character with my account just
don't let him do it people think this is
me 6,000 people every day think that's
me alright take that in a month six
thousand three hundred that's roughly
two hundred thousand a month which
calculates to two million a year and
this is just one channel you will click
on this link what happens o gifts for my
subscribers we all know there's a lot of
young kids at YouTube who don't know
better they see this and they think oh
my god PewDiePie wants to give me a gift
well not my fans cuz they're not [ __ ]
idiots
but I imagine other people are what do
we what do I want I want a galaxy I have
one what you get a thousand galaxy s7
that's a lot I 7 phones man that is
attempt it off I was gonna say yes to
one but now I get a thousand oh there's
a there's even a chat here this is
really working is this really working
yep it works it's for subscribers only
they obviously put a lot of effort into
making this seem real alright okay I
want an iPhone give me an iPhone which
oh I guess like color that's pretty
generous proceed for human verification
oh never mind download an app to prove
that you are human four of the offers to
unlock the content ok Tesco versus Argos
so it's basically advertisements you're
filling in advertisements making these
people money kill yourself
another thing that blows my mind how
stupid it is and this is something not
just me but a lot of youtubers have
pointed this out for years if there's a
really stupid comment that you want to
maybe explain something to if you reply
to that comment their comment will get
bumped while your comment will get
buried why doesn't he just show my
answer underneath like this it's that so
hard why does this things take year to
implement the scheme that YouTube
essentially is closing their eyes on for
years I am so tired of it and sick of it
and I'm just want my comments to be
functioning they're not pretty pie
you're such a crybaby where do you care
well commons it's the main thing
feedback I get from my friends I want to
understand what they think and what they
say if the Commons gets abused then I
can't use it last time I had to turn
them off just hoping YouTube would do
something and I gave them a bunch of
feedback that time that was this was
years ago by the way I said moderators I
said don't let people have the same name
don't let people post links why would
you give people more freedom to post
links why would you need to link
something in the comments who didn't
realize that's a terrible [ __ ] idea
we have this broken s system that never
[ __ ] works what should we do with it
oh I know let's give them more freedom
that's the Google way I've called to
action before I said hey fans can you
help me clean out the comments can you
help me flag or report it doesn't work
like that a lot of these features does
exist on YouTube there are ways to have
moderators but it's so inefficient no
one knows about it on Twitch however
it's so easy slash mod whatever person
they can help clean out the shed not a
problem
I'm one person with 45 46 million people
am I supposed to just moderate that
myself when clearly I have a ton of fans
who could help me out why people can add
subtitles literally there's the option
for anyone to put subtitles on my
without any moderation why why can we
give them that freedom but not moderate
the comments can we please just have
moderated comments please YouTube I'm
begging you it's such a simple solution
which what I understand for you seems to
be a complicated problem I'm sick of
this I love you YouTube but you don't
listen goodbye I'm just gonna go this
time alright well that was smile rant
got a little worked up there and thank
you for leaving like appreciate it tweet
the hashtag make comments on youtube not
so [ __ ] please just add moderators it
will make that trend stay awesome brush
it's it's been bothering me for so long
now I've been trying to find solutions
to it I've been hoping that it would get
better
I was hoping YouTube would try to figure
a way out but it doesn't seem like it
and I'm sick of it so I'm gonna turn the
comments off forever they're not coming
back this time around and I hope you
understand my decision I'm doing that I
wouldn't say this something I would say
it as taking the next step in the right
direction